Sí la verdad es que la reacción no se ha
hecho esperar Donald Trump ha dicho que
se trata de una persecución política ha
dicho también que es la mayor
interferencia en un proceso electoral
palabras textuales ha dicho a mí me
votasteis y me elegisteis como
presidente y la derecha radical está
llevando a cabo una caza de brujas para
acabar con nuestro país también hemos
podido leer un comunicado que han
enviado los propios Abogados del
expresidente Donald Trump en el que
quieren dejar Claro que Trump no ha sido
de momento declarado culpable esto es
solamente una acusación se trata de un
enjuiciamiento político han dicho que
pelearemos ante los tribunales hemos
podido leer también las declaraciones
que ha hecho el abogado Michael coel en
el que fue abogado del expresidente
Donald Trump Michael cohen ha dicho que
esto le da una esperanza de que nadie
está por encima de la justicia a quien
de momento no hemos escuchado al
departamento de Justicia ni tampoco Al
fiscal de Manhattan que ha llevado este
caso Alvin brack Que de momento
permanece dentro de la fiscalía como
sabéis era un caso en el que muy poca
gente confiaba porque la investigación
era bastante débil Comparado con el
resto de causas que tenía Donald Trump
pero aún así él siguió apostando por
ello un Donald Trump que por cierto
Fuentes cercanas a él y de su entorno
aseguran que se encuentra en mar al lago
y que no se esperaba para nada este
anuncio